très bien et on prendra à gauche s
kenard conduire avant sa majorité ce
sera désormais possible depuis le 1er
janvier 2024 les adolescents de 17 ans
peuvent conduire dès l'obtention du
permis B auparavant il était possible de
l'obtenir avant sa majorité grâce à la
conduite accompagné mais il fallait
attendre 18 ans pour pouvoir conduire en
toute liberté cette liberté et cette
autonomie c'est ce que souhait sukaina
et Elise toutes les deux élèves dans
cette auto-école à montinil Bretonneux
ça permet de d'ouvrir des portes même ça
nous permet d'être plus autonome des
très jeunes notamment pour le sport ou
pour aller voir ma famille quihabite pas
à côté je pense que ça peut être
pratique et de pouvoir y aller sans
forcément déranger l'un de mes parents
ou de prendre les transports j'en
profiterai parce que enfin j'ai ça
permet de libérer d'une certaine façon
mes parents parce que vu que j'ai un
emplo du temps assez chargé ça
permettrait de de les laisser un peu
plus plus avoir du temps cette mesure
est l'avantage aussi de nombreux parents
qui n'auront plus besoin d'accompagner
leur enfant presque majeur ça va
m'alléger dans le sens où elle va
pouvoir bah conduire toute seule ù
j'aurais plus besoin de l'emmener à
droite à gauche elise a énormément de
d'activités donc il est vrai qu'à partir
du moment où elle va être autonome ça ça
va n permettre d'être d'être plus
autonome et et de me laisser plus autant
qu'elle que moi pour Sandy démaré
monitrice à Montini le Bretonneux cette
mesure laisse place à quelques
questionnements notamment en ce qui
concerne les délaiis de passage du
permis de conduire c'est une crainte
dont on a tous beaucoup parlé dans la
profession les élèves vont nous demandé
de passer leur permis en direct un peu
plus rapidement on nous a certifié au
niveau du ministère notamment par une
note que il y a des déblocages
d'inspecteurs en mars prochain
l'autoécole prévoit déjà d'accueillir un
nouveau moniteur pour répondre à la
demande mais les élèves doivent aussi
anticiper leurs inscriptions on leur a
demandé d'anticiper d'anticiper un petit
peu plus sur leur formation de façon à
ce que au 2 janvier ils s'attendent pas
à passer leur permis dès le 2 janvier
mais qu'on puisse étaler toutes leur
formation comme il faut à 17 ans les
adolescents titulaires du permis de
conduire resteront pénalement
responsables en cas d'accident mais la
responsabilité financière reviendra aux
parents tant qu'ils n'auront pas atteint
leur majorité